i've got the funniest fact check i have
ever read in my entire life
okay so here's the fact check from usa
today
the fact check is about a claim
that ukraine not only had obviously been
cozying up to the west for many years
before this invasion
but
that specifically they'd been cozying up
to liberal politicians in the west
because liberal politicians are the
ruling elite in the west and
specifically they've been cozying up to
the clinton so here's the claim you
probably have seen it going around
facebook or twitter or instagram the
claim is that
ukraine was the largest donor to the
clinton foundation from 1999 to 2014.
in usa today takes this obviously here's
the claim similar rumors about ukrainian
financial donations to the clinton
foundation have gained traction
on twitter
representative marjorie taylor green
promoted an iteration of this claim
during a february 19th rally
fact ukraine was the single largest
owner two the clinton foundation has
gained a hundred likes
but the post misrepresents a chart from
2015
which ranks individual contributions to
the foundation based on nationality as
factcheck.org reported in 2019 the
clinton foundation hasn't received
donations from the ukrainian government
i'm going to pause it right there the
post never said
that the clinton foundation got got
money from the ukrainian government
by the way
democrat elite
political operatives have gotten money
from the ukrainian government when you
think of hunter biden for instance has a
no-show job with a state
energy company burisma in ukraine that
is the ukrainian government giving money
to democrats but okay let's put that
aside the post never says
the ukrainian government was the largest
owner to the it said ukraine
ukraine the people of ukraine
ukraine through its various
channels was the largest donor to the
clinton foundation usa today reached out
to the social medias who shared this
claim for comment do you want to recant
your claims people your stupid crazy
conspiracy theory wait a second hold on
the wall street journal
oh hold on so the the headlines is the
posts misused reports on individual
donations so how do they misuse it the
wall street journal published a report
in 2015 on individual donations over 50
thousand dollars made to the clinton
foundation 1999-2014
the article included a chart listing the
top foreign donors
ukraine tops the list
but the graph doesn't support the claim
in the social media post hold on
the the social media post says from 1999
to 2014 ukraine top donor to the clinton
foundation
the fact check says
uh in in this chart from 1999 to 2014
ukraine tops the list
but the graph doesn't support the claim
that is literally the claim that is in
those exact words that is the claim
but no fact check
no it because the graph doesn't reflect
donations from the governments which the
posts aren't really focused on
uh so therefore you know it's just yeah
ukrainians contributed 10 million
dollars to the clinton foundation don't
forget by the way ukraine's a relatively
poor country
i where did this 10 million dollars come
from i don't know do you think some of
it might have come from kind of dodgy
oligarchic sources in ukraine oh i don't
know i don't know i'm just asking
questions
ukrainians contributed 10 million more
than any other nationality
most of that money came from ukrainian
businessman and philanthropist victor
pinchuk victor pinchook's foundation
based in kiev donated
8.6 million dollars to the foundation
between 2009 and 2013.
the article notes that pinchuk has close
government ties and he served as a
member of ukrainian parliament from 1998
oh and sorry he's the son-in-law of
former ukrainian president lenin kuchma
this
your fact check is proving the posts to
be 100
completely correct therefore these
liberal fact checkers quote unquote rate
at 17 million pinocchio's total lies
fake news fake news censor anyone
who reports on the truth between the
democrats crooked relationship
between uh ukrainian oligarchs and
and crooked politicians here in the
united states
fact check fact check totally false
totally
all the facts are true but the fact
check is false
the reason by the way
that
liberals post these ridiculous fact
checks where the headlines is fact check
republican claim totally false
fake news and then in the article they
admit that the fact the fact the facts
of the matter were totally right
in the in the article they they note
that there are things the republicans
actually said were totally right the
reason they do that is because these
fact-checking organizations have
relationships with all the big social
media companies
and the social media companies rely on
the fact checkers to determine what will
be promoted or censored in the algorithm
so even if the fact checkers quote
unquote have even the modicum of
integrity to admit that the claims are
true in the article as long as the final
verdict is that this is fake news it
will be
censored as
this sort of information has been now
for years right now go to rockauto.com
enter the word knowles in their how did
you hear bettisbox so they know that i
sent you you're gonna then send me a
thank you note because when you go to
rockauto.com you're going to save so
much you could save
20
30
50 on your auto parts for the exact same
auto parts you don't need to drive to
the brick and mortar store you don't
need to answer a thousand questions you
don't need to wait for the guy to go in
the back only to not have your part so
that you got to go back and you got to
go online just pull out your phone right
now save save all that money they got
the same prices for pros and
do-it-yourselfers there's no gimmicks
you don't have to wait until tuesday at
3 a.m to go log on it's a special sale
no always reliably low prices the
website is so easy to navigate even i
can do it you just go pull out your
phone
get on your computer type in
rockauto.com
you can see all the parts available for
your car or truck go get them now and
then write knowles k-n-w-l-e-s
in their how did you hear bettis box so
they know that we sent you
did you like that clip i'm so glad you
know we're entering into a penitential
season right now and and one thing that
i would recommend giving up for lent
would be all the other podcasts other
than mine
you obviously you should continue to
listen to my podcast but you could give
up all of the other ones and then you'll
have time to listen to more of my
episodes which you can get at apple
podcast spotify stitch or google play
type in the michael knowles show
subscribe
leave a five-star review obviously ring
the bell here we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you